thank you dorsa alice congratulations
you're starting to string some victories
together how do you feel about your last
couple of games yeah i mean of course uh
the previous game it was kind of
unexpected that i was able to win
um
but uh to get that end game i seem to be
kind of losing but this game i thought
it was um
i thought that i kind of was pressing
the entire time
um
so like out of the opening i was able to
win upon and i was able to keep it there
was a moment like later where i felt
that
my position might not be winning
that was later when like
so
i think i knew all this up to bishop d2
that was still your preparation yes
yeah i'm not sure because i think after
b3 i was planning to play knight b6 but
bishop d2
bishop detune knight b6 i wasn't sure
whether it was as good but i think it
was okay
um
and after a takes b6 rook c1 queen d5
now she could play b3 but like i don't
think she really wanted to because i
might be able to win the a2 pawn and
it's always a long term weakness
and in which case the b3 pawn would be
really weak
so she decided to sacrifice it
with 91.
and uh at this point you're already
feeling quite good about your chances i
would assume right yeah um
after
queen d5 and she was able to play this
f3 move
here i didn't like my position quite as
much because
i think if like knight f6 and
e4 and
it looks like i'm losing the pawn
um but
so like knight d6 of course the c5 pawn
drops so i have to play knight g5 but
now my nike knight is really awkwardly
placed um
after e4
queen check
and then i played rook d8
uh i'm not sure whether it was good or
not but i think it was okay
after knight f4 oh yeah uh i was
expecting her to play h4 maybe
maybe knight f2 knight f2 here okay
and it looks like yeah now she's
threatening h4 and she might have some
um d1 ideas where my queen is kind of
awkwardly placed but i think i was
calculating that i should still be able
to keep the pawn
um
after here
uh i wasn't sure whether i was winning
or not because i guess she could have
exchanged queens
i'm not sure how good it would have been
but if she exchanged queens i think she
could have tried to amuse the fact that
my c5 pun is weak and my knight is out
of the games and her night is also still
good so she can try to like maybe win
the c5 pawn uh do rook b5 and then like
try to harass my b-pan with a rook and
knight
[Music]
and then you guys
went into this
uh variation kept a lot of pieces on the
board but at the same time a lot of
things unfortunately for her for
zoe they were going quite wrong and
she was up a pawn but unfortunately all
her pieces are in very very bad shape
right now
now
you uh came up with this idea of rook 31
and queen to d5 finished it off nicely
congratulations uh alice now uh tell us
a little bit about your show what's
happening with alice's pawn palace while
you play these tournaments do you still
do the show in between games what's uh
what's the status of that um well
usually uh
i do the show like
once every few months um
but i
i am mostly focusing on this tournament
so i'm not doing it during the game but
i'll probably do one hopefully soon
after the tournament well big congrats
from us and all the panel string those
victories and we'll see you in the
championship rounds thank you
well done well done very well done
and i just wanted to sorry
i wanted to turn